وسائل التواصل اجتماعي زادت من استخدام
وانتشار الاخبار المزيفه والكاذبه حتى
انها تجي طريقها الى وسائل الاعلام
الرئيسيه ايضا لكن اللغويين في جامعه
اوصلو النرويجيه مع خبراء اذا كان الصناعي
يعملون على فتح لغه الاخبار الكاذبه
والمزيفه والتي يسمونها ثيك سبيك فاثناء
البحث تبين ان نصوص المزيفه تكون مختلفه
من حيث اسلوب صياغتها بالاضافه الى العديد
من الاختلافات اللغويه الكبيره فمثلا كان
للنصوص الزائفه اسلوب غير رسمي اكثر كما
لحظت في النصوص المزيفه كثرت استخدام
الافعال خاصه في زمن المضارع بالاضافه الى
ذلك كانت الضمائر والصفات والكلمات
والتدخلات الملونه
مختلفه بالهدف مكافحه الاخبار المزيفه على
الانترنت وتحسين ادوات التحقق من صدقيات
هذه المنشوره
على كل حال سالنا الناس متى تشعر بان
الخبر الذي تقراه كاذب ومزيف
[موسيقى]
اختلفت اليوم الاخبار عن السابق متعدده
المصادر التي نحصل منها على المعلومات في
السابق تلقى الاخبار عن طريق الصحف او
القنوات التلفزيونيه اما اليوم فاصبحت
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في الوسيله التي
نتلقى منها الاخبار بشكل اسرع واسهل هذا
بكل تاكيد اثر على مستقيه المعلومات فمتى
نشعر بان الخبر مزيف او كاذب
[موسيقى]
الكره الخبر كاذب او مزيف اذا كان من مصدر
مو موثوق
من الحسابات اذا كانت رسميه وموثوقه او من
جهه رسميه والله من البدايه احيانا يكون
الخبر في التمهيد حقها واضح انه صحيح غير
كذا ما يكون موجود في التلفزيون او في
الصحف الرسميه اذا كان الخبر النصر غير
موثوق او ما هو مكان رسميه
كثيره
واغلبها من الحسابات مزيفه يعني في مصادر
فيه حسابات في تويتر يعني معتمده مثلا من
قبل الجهات الرسميه وكاله الانباء
السعوديه اخبار كثير ولكن
فاهم على حسب مصدر الخبر من وين
اكبر من اخبار او من جريده هنا يعني اثق
بالخبر نفسك يعني غير لما يكون من اشخاص
واطراف وكلام زايد لما بيكون مش من جهر
رسميه اكيد الخبر كاذب ومزيف واذا كان من
جهر رسميه او من حدا موثوق انه اكيد الخبر
بيكون مزبوط الاخبار جايه ما هي من قنوات
رسميه مواقع التلفزيون شيء رسمي فهو خبر
غير صحيح
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من بيروت جوز هند صحفيه في
خدمه تقصي صحه الاخبار في وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا صباح
العربيه
صباح الخير طيب احنا نسال سؤال انت كخبيره
بالموضوع هل بالفعل للاخبار المزيفه
والكاذبه لغه يمكن ان تكشف
يعني بحسب الخبره يعني بنشوف فيها الاخبار
المزيفه بنلاحظ انه النصوص اللي بتستخدم
واللغه التي تستخدم بالاخبار المظله او
المزيفه همم بتعتمد مختلف يعني بنلاحظ انه
تستخدم لغه عواطف اوقات لغه ركيكه تستخدم
دائما صيغه المجهول او النفي همم
يسيطر احيان كثيره يعني فينا نقول انه
الاوجه تبع همم اللغه اللغه بتختلف بحسب
هدف المنشور المدمر
هل من خدمه معينه برنامج معين يمكن الحديث
عنه لكشف الاخبار المزيفه مثلا انتم في
وكاله صحافه الفرنسيه هل تتبعون هذه
الوسيله
نعم هلا ناحيه اللغه بعد
برنامج محدد كرمال نكسف هذا الموضوع ولكن
في ادوات وتقنيه اخرى بتعمل هي بتكون
مفتوحه المصدر نحن بنعتمدها للكشف مثلا عن
الصور عن المقاطع الفيديو او في مثلا امور
اخرى تستخدم
للنصوص ولكن لا نتحدثون عن اللغه
اللغه
نحن لم نعت انه نشوفها بالاخبار موثوق بها
وبالتالي الادوات والتقنيات اليوم او
البرامج لا تغطي اللغه
التواصل الاجتماعي انتشرت همم بسرعه
الاخبار الكاذبه والاخبار الزئيفه انتم
كخبراء في هذا المجال ماذا تنصحون
المتابعه العادي ليكشف الاخبار الكاذبه
والزاعي عن اخبار الصادقه
نعم اولا ودائما من نوصل انه نلجا الى
المصدر يعني الخبر الذي ليس له مصدر نحن
بنجرب من صدره وما من شربوا همم ايضا
الانتباه للتفاصيل الصغيره بالمنشورات في
الاحيان بيبدعوا المروجين لاخبار الكاريبي
لنا مثلا تجري باوقات محدده او مثلا
باميكن همم محدده من العالم
والامور الصغيره بالصوره او الفيديو تشير
الى اصدقاءك باماكن اخرى همم بالاضافه الى
ذلك في كثير من المستخدمين اليوم وخصوصا
انه العالم عام معلوماته بشكل اكبر من
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في كثير اشخاص عم
يتنبهوا لا انه المنشورات مزيفه وعم بيعلق
التعليقات للقول انه هذه المنشورات مزيفه
فمش غلط ابدا
ضاع الى تعليقات المستخدمين اذا حسينا نحن
بدنا نشارك هذا المنشور
وايضا اضيف انه في حال نحن شكينا او جينا
شك صغير بانه المنشور مظلل فينا ببساطه
عدم مشاركته لان المشاركه اليوم بتكون عم
بتساهم بانتشاره بنرجع للغه اللي هي
الاساس لانه عم يستخدموا عاده لغه العواطف
اما ناخذ صوره مثيره للمشاعر ومنحط معها
نص مثير ايضا هذا نوع من النصوص بيشد
المستخدم له مشاركه المعلومات اللي ممكن
اكون مظلله بهذه المنشورات احنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر من بيروت جويس حنا صحفيه في
خدمه تقسي صحه الاخبار في وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه